[Music]
I'm scared
only I'm here
oh
[Applause]
yeah
give way to Christ
the lifter of my heads
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Lord repel this Devil's Powers by the
Incarnation
resurrection and Ascension of our Lord
Jesus Christ I command you to depart
this child of God
[Music]
okay
thank you
father
I don't know
The Citadel Has Fallen
the walls have crumbled
black smoke blots out the Sun
because as some of you may already know
we have a female student in a class
as an observer
Sister Anne will be accompanying us on
our rounds for the rest of the term
now pay close attention
the nuances of aircraft require active
learning to truly understand
so group one
let's descend into the mouth of Hell
shall we
as a child I knew it was
more
more
I didn't have a name for it
every night she would come to my room
sometimes she was my mother
and sometimes she wasn't
[Music]
she'd comb my hair
she'd hung that song
[Music]
[Applause]
should hurt me
and then she'd hold me and cry and say
the voice inside her head made her do it
I'm so sorry Anne
abuse at the hands of someone you trust
is my mother was incapable of hurting me
she loved me
it was the thing inside her
she was possessed
I know it's unusual in this day and age
to devote your life to something
spiritual hey good morning but ever
since my mother's issues I've always
felt a calling to help people
[Music]
finally's parents believe that she is
being possessed by some sort of evil
entity
she's not as scary as she looks she can
hear you
you're my favorite person here us girls
we gotta stick together in this place
we have a female student in the class
only as an observer because as you know
women are strictly forbidden from
performing exorcism female surgeons are
once Unthinkable somebody had to be the
first
when you enter the room of the possessed
you are walking onto a Battlefield
strike Terror Lord into the Beast now
defiling this innocent child
[Music]
[Music]
you have a gift I'd like to teach you
this relationship it's personal we all
have a personal relationship with God
it's with God
this feeling has followed me my entire
life
you got my invitation
we've been waiting for you
[Music]
foreign
ER sets this movie apart from other
movies she's delivering a strong
well-crafted multi-dimensional
performance in a genre that has seen it
all and I think her performance and I
think the character of Anne is a first
if you're a horror fan this is sort of
an integral viewing experience the story
of The Strand coming up against the
patriarchy of the Catholic church was
really an interesting place to explore
and I really think that we wanted to
show all the different Dynamics when
you're in such a male-driven world and
and I think each character kind of had a
different relationship with Sister Anne
and a different way of expressing that
patriarchy the aspect of prejudice
against women was one that fascinated me
from the beginning about the story and
it was something I wanted to explore not
something that we hit the audience over
the head with kind of in a lecturing way
or preaching way but just in a way that
was almost common sense to me if you
have someone who's willing to do the job
and it has the talent to do the job
because she's a woman does that prevent
her does that negate her from being able
to do it in the church as it stands now
it does it was an excellent opportunity
to take a look at what if we have this
strong female protagonist that went
through this journey I think if we're
using art to hold up a mirror to society
right now and have a conversation I
think that's the conversation that this
this specific piece of art will evoke I
think people will talk about this and so
I'm proud of it in that way you know I'm
technically speaking you know I'm not
the first female Exorcist so the first
in seven centuries
I'll take it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]